one thing I have started to notice now
that you know every time we go to a
different country and we've hung out
with like other content creators is that
started notes is a pattern where every
time they want to take us out to dinner
it's chill out or you know have like a
nice dinner
it's always a [__] Japanese Place how
the [__] did this does this happen every
single time well I think there's a lot
of people in LA but I realize they used
to eat Asian food the most yeah in
general and then like you want uh Korean
Korean yes yeah it's just like you know
when we when we travel abroad I'm used
to I I want to have like give me like
the fattest American steak or something
and everyone's like so I booked out this
Japanese Place uh it's a really trendy
Jack because I've realized they're like
you guys live in Japan you like Japanese
yeah because I've realized that all the
trendy places especially like all the
trendy places in uh LA and California
and now like I guess Australia all of
the trendiest places are like Japanese
like Chad took us to that [__]
Japanese restaurant exactly and I'm just
like Chad you're new yeah
why yeah that was that was okay as well
I mean it's pretty good it was good I
mean it's I'm all complaining it's just
I feel like this is
the uh I I feel like this is the
sacrifice we have made for living in
Japan which is like all the food here is
like Japanese food is just great and
then you go back and then everyone wants
to eat at like trendy Japanese
restaurants I don't know why it's like
especially Japanese uh Cuisine that has
been propped up in such a way where it's
become kind of like
a very like high class not not really
high class very bougie kind of like
Place yeah because it's like I think the
whole difference between the Japanese
food culture and like the western food
culture is just so different right like
not only with like the actual items of
the foods but also just like the way
it's presented and like yeah how courses
work and [__] like that like especially
because like Japan is very much a
culture where it's like it's not just
like here's one big main dish and that's
your food it's more like lots of small
little dishes so I think the Western
idea of it being like well if there's
multiple items that are coming out it's
like a course meal so that's fancy when
in reality it's like you can achieve
that same thing at an Izakaya but it's
not fancy at all right so yeah I didn't
need a lot of the food that I normally
look forward to like I don't need any
wings I don't think I had any Mexican
food what uh yeah I don't think I had
any Mexican food because I don't like
you yeah I normally really look forward
to that I had it in now but it was one
of the worst ones I've ever had yeah it
was just dude the fries was even worse
than all I know the most popular it was
like the worst okay um I I did have one
thing I always like the one thing I
always look for when I come to La pretty
much the only thing I look forward to
Green Barbecue yes yeah uh me and Korean
barbecue is like especially okay I don't
know if this is like Blasphemous to say
uh but like I think the Korean barbecue
in La is better than any of the Korean
barbecues you can get here in Japan and
I don't know why yeah well that's
because Japan puts more effort into
Yakiniku yeah dude which is different I
feel like some America like credit to
them the Korean barbecue or you can eat
are so [__] yeah yeah [__]
actually like actually yeah yeah I mean
I don't have I don't I don't have too
much of like a
I I don't I don't have too much of a uh
was it sample size because I've only
been to Korea like once for a weekend
but you know I I [__] ate as much
Korean barbecue as I could uh as I could
fit in that time it was basically Korean
barbecue for dinner for like every day
and the Korean barbecue I had on that
one trip wasn't like it was it was good
it was [__] fantastic but I feel the
Korean barbecue in Korea yeah it's kind
of like halfway between Japanese
Yakiniku and the American cream yeah
where it's like it's still you know it's
still got like the essence of the
American ice cream barbecue where it's
just like just bring out a shitload of
meat and it's all [__] good but they
also there's also like a delicacy to it
that's very much synonymous yeah
Japanese yakimiku yeah yeah yeah I I I
would say I actually from what I've
tried so far unless anyone has any
recommendations because we're going to
Korea I'm going to Career like pretty
soon uh I've not found a Korean barbecue
uh yet that has matched some of my
favorite ones in La yeah they're doing
good though yeah there's just something
about the American culture of just in
Indulgence and just being like just have
as much as you want yeah if I pay 50
bucks in America for all you can eat
yeah and barbecue and I pay 50 bucks for
all you can eat in Japan what I'm
getting is two so difficult yeah yeah 50
bucks all you can in Japan I'm scared
yeah I'm like where did they get this
meat from yeah it certainly was in Japan
uh you know because Japan also has a big
import culture of with beef and chicken
and yeah they import a lot of it
obviously we hear about wagyu all the
time but wagyu is the [__] that they
grow here yeah also that's like a small
percentage Yeah Yeah and and you know
there's a lot of so basically like a lot
of the meat you get especially when you
go to yakimik places especially if it's
a cheap place or you can eat you're
often getting a lot of imported meat and
it's like it's fine it's fine but I fell
in America when you get the 50 all you
can eat thing and they're like the
seasons so well as well because in Japan
they don't season [__] and it's fine but
sometimes I want the pork belly that has
been marinated all day in the spicy
sauce that's just fire yeah look I I get
Japanese Cuisine especially Japanese
Cuisine where it's just like it's all
about the natural flavor like they've
been taken over by the British with like
how little seasoning they use sometimes
on stuff and it's just crazy yeah and
it's just like this cow has been
listening to Mozart every day or some
[__] like that he gets massage
everything yeah Olive wagyu yeah yeah
yeah they feed only olives to the cow
it's like how about we
just I'm like I'm like [__] I'm
tired give me all of the spike give me
as much spices as you can of one piece
of meat and call it a day and it's gonna
taste [__] amazing yeah I'm like yeah
American Life American like uh American
Cuisine I feel like has that like right
balance of being like we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna got a little bit of
everything you know we're not gonna do a
thing one's way but what we can
guarantee is you can eat a [__] ton of
this [__] it's got like the
addictiveness of fast food yeah even
though it's not fast food yeah yeah and
I don't know how they achieve that yeah
but all of course also I've because I
was talking to Emily about this uh and
she was like uh because I I was saying
like I feel like Korean food not just
green barbecue but just Korean food in
general is uh I've had better Korean
food in uh the US and England than I
have found here in Japan uh and I'm like
why is that is and uh and we're having
like this really cut long conversation
of just like is there like is it because
of the Rivalry here because she was
saying that when she she was saying that
when she's in Korea it's hard to find
good Japanese food so you'd think that
by them being neighbors you could easily
find like good Korean restaurants in
Japan a good Japan Japanese restaurants
in Korea but uh she was saying yeah it's
actually like really hard to find good
Japanese restaurants in Korea because
because of the Rivalry probably maybe
it's the Rivalry maybe people just want
to more focus on their own Cuisine
rather than or maybe it's this idea of
because they're so close by like it's
literally a one a two-hour flight from
Tokyo to Seoul yeah like because it's so
close by maybe there's no need for there
to be a good counterpart in each country
because it's like well if you want the
counterpart just fly two hours because
like and you can get it I wonder if I
wonder if this is a thing in like
European countries as well because I I
don't know because I feel like obviously
in England we have a lot of other
European restaurants because British
Cuisine sucks so we have to we have to
borrow other Cuisines but I'm like you
know can you find like Spanish food good
Spanish food in France or do people just
go you definitely can you're right I
think so at least I I but then again I'm
not going to France to eat Spanish food
that's true that's true so there's also
that you know like I don't think
there'll be anyone who's like in Germany
and being like uh yes I really want
Italian food right now um so [__] the
German food bro I can't wear you on the
world I always want Italian food
that's the one I've always got time
where it's like no matter which country
there's always at least one good Italian
restaurant I'm [__] mad man they got
such good food they get it man they
Chief Peak I don't know how you guys do
it I will admit I think I because when I
was when we were in uh when we're in La
I we try and do Korean BBQ but a lot of
the time I would just get like bibimba
yeah
I swear to God I've never had a good one
here I don't know why it doesn't go as
hard yeah I thought okay ones yeah
there's some good ones but definitely
the ones in Korea are better for sure
they're great as well I feel like my
problem with the Biven bar here as well
as a tiny they don't like the beaten
bars in La I don't know if they're big
in Korea but like they're [__] big
bowl they're pretty big yeah more
surface area for the rice to get [__]
on I love it and I like dude it's so
good and I had one here and I paid like
30 bucks for it it was Tiny I was like
there's
get me out of here
yeah yeah I don't know I yeah I think uh
but the cream Fried Chicken is pretty
good I do like that I've got a spot here
I love and chinookable it's so [__]
good Korean well see Uncle Bill is
basically Korea so dude
basically I think I took Pete there on
stream it's like the this place in
chinooka boy it's dude the Fried Chicken
they do is nuts oh I think I know which
one I've never been there I think Nabi
took me there originally yeah
yes it's a wooden chairs
insane dude I've never had fried chicken
that good in my life I I and all other
Fried Chicken pale's in comparison right
that's amazingly the best fried chicken
I've had I mean the best fried chicken
I've ever had in my life is in Korea
actually yeah so I mean yeah
that was Peak and then I went to a uh
Korean fried chicken place in Seoul and
I was like this just blows everything up
okay yeah I know yeah we'll see about
that they know how to do it we we will
see about that yeah me and Connor
planning to go to Worlds this year in
Korea so we'll do it hopefully yeah yeah
we gotta get tickets still I don't even
know most of the tickets
hopefully we can get that all sorted
yeah